hi Samuel Leeds here and one of the
strategies that myself and my success
students are doing really well at the
moment is buying properties but rather
than leaving and money in the property
we are adding value to it and then
refinancing the property and pulling an
money back out which is a fabulous
strategy now the biggest danger in this
is that when you try and refinance the
property is that it gets down valued so
on this video I've got the top five ways
to make sure that your surveyor does not
down value your property hence meaning
that you can pull all almost of your
money out so the five ways to increase
your property valuation the first way is
when the valuer goes out to the property
always always always always make sure
that you go out there - that you meet
the value of the property when you meet
him there or her just be friendly be
nice dress well and don't get there and
say what do you think what do you think
what do you think the value is because
that's what people always do and it just
annoys the valuers so just get there be
professional be friendly build some
rapport and be ready to answer questions
that's the first way to make sure that
you're onto a good start number two next
is the valuer they're not stupid they
know what you paid for that house and
you probably got it at a little bit of a
bargain so what a lot of people do is
they try and hide the fact they don't
they might have bought the house really
cheap for say fifty thousand pounds and
now they've spent 20 grand on it they've
put seventy thousand in total and they
think it's worth a hundred but rather
than mean honest and just saying you
know what I actually got this really
cheap I bought it for fifty thousand and
here's why I managed to go so cheap
here's how it happened instead they just
try and hope that the valuer doesn't
know how much they paid for it doesn't
research doesn't find out well they will
know exactly what you paid for it don't
know when you bought it as well so step
number two is to just or tip number two
it's just to be honest just say you know
what I actually got this for fifty
thousand pounds the reason I managed to
get it so cheap is because I bought
three off the landlord and he was in a
real hurry to move because yet I had
some bad talents and this was the story
and I bought all three of them and a
little bit of a bargain number three
demonstrate and show the valuer
exactly what you've done to the property
how have you added so much value be
ready to show the invoices and the
receipts and what you've done just if I
back up exact
how much value that is and why you think
these properties is worth more now than
it was when you bought it
next number four this is so so so
important you can follow the first three
steps so far and you can you can win the
value over and you can sense that he's
onside and he can be really impressed
and he can really like you and in his
mind he might be thinking yeah this is
worth one hundred thousand pound which
is perfect but then he goes and he views
more properties all day back-to-back and
he forgets about you and he forgets
about your property and then he's there
at his desk and he's thinking oh what
was this one he gets mixed up and then
Bank he gives you your very low
valuation you think what I was I was so
convinced so how do you get around that
before the valuer leaves what I was
doing I really like to do is I'll make a
loop hat for him a little folder and I
put the before and the after pictures
and I put the receipts I put it all
together in a little presentation folder
and I say to him look thank you so much
for your time I look forward to hearing
from you please can I leave you this
picture the front of the house on the
front with the address all the pictures
before and after that way when he's back
in his office thinking teeny what was
that one again and what he's got it
right in front of him that is such a
massive tip I can't even emphasize how
much difference that might make do you
be able to rebound your property at high
amount and lastly number five and you
might not like this one super much but
it's just prepare for the worst prepare
for a lower valuation than you hoped the
problem with the strategy of buying and
then adding value and refinancing is
when you're relying on a surveyors
opinion which is effectively what it is
how much is a house worth what a house
is worth what someone's per bed's paid
for it's a subjective figure and when
you're completely banking on someone's
subjective opinion and if they give you
a down valuation you're screwed because
you bought the house on credit cards and
just prepare for the worst be realistic
and expect the valuer
to lower it value than you think it's
easy and property investing to get
really carried away to be really
optimistic and to be able to say well
this this one sold for this much
therefore the value is definitely going
to vary my mouth prepare for the worst
be conservative if the figures do not
stack up with you leaving some money in
then don't go ahead with a deal in the
first place so there we go there were
the five ways to increase your property
valuation and also to make a success of
the strategy
of buying refurbishing and refinancing
all of your money out I hope you found
that helpful please do comment your
thoughts comments and experiences below
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification but um right now I'll see
you next time
[Music]